in the YouTube world your followers are
your currency and if you've got over
10,000 of them then you can use one of
the sets here at the YouTube space in
Berlin move around your VR goggles your
smartphone or Mouse to follow me you can
also use the equipment here and get
expertise from professionals these guys
are using virtual reality to create
fashion on a virtual mannequin as you
can see up here on the screens but let
me take your next door to another person
whose business is fashion just in the
quad
she's a video blogger and has over
100,000 subscribers how everyone is
Justin if they wanted to make a video on
sizing in fashion for a while now since
there's been this huge not a scandal but
a discussion about who should be called
the plus-size and who should it it's the
topic that's very confusing for everyone
so I'd like to bring clarity with that
video so Justina your one take wonder
nope I feel many fakes I edit out most
of them and it just keeps me essence
without the causes do you do you prefer
actually working here or wouldn't it be
easier at home because it holds a lot
more relaxed and youdo you have ratio
your stuff in your to do that home when
you come here it's a bubble where you
can take time have the room all the
materials and be help from the guys here
who are experts and what about the
financial side you're famous and you
also reach and neither think nor reach
at this point maybe one day right now
it's just a knife I've done in a
creative source of inspiration for me
supporting my fashion label cool ok nice
talking to you see thank you so much
but the bigger production there's even a
fully-equipped studio self-operated but
enough for me enjoy the music
[Music]